good morning shadow chancellor um
i'm going to come to you on the things
i've been discussing with the education
section in a second but uh you said this
morning that your big plan to deal with
this cost of living crisis is a windfall
tax on north sea oil and gas producers
how's that going to work in a declining
industry uh
and one which basically isn't producing
much in the way of profits at the moment
anyway
well we've had 10 years more than a
decade of dither and delay and
incompetence from this government which
is why we have this energy price crisis
today of course prices have gone up
globally but we are uniquely exposed in
britain because of the decisions of this
government it's a failure to regulate
properly to get rid of our gas storage
and a failure to retrofit homes and to
go with the speed on new nuclear and
renewables that are necessary and that's
why today i'm putting up forward a
package of measures to keep bills down
this april to help families and
pensioners who are struggling with this
cost of living crisis that is coming in
april and it is right to ask those who
have benefited from high higher gas and
oil prices to pay more into the system
and that's why i'm putting forward a
one-off increase in the taxes paid by
north sea oil and gas they are likely to
make record profits uh this year because
of that spike in prices let's tax them a
bit more and use that money to reduce
bills for ordinary people who are
struggling so much at the moment and we
estimate that um just because of the
higher
prices already the oil and gas industry
in the north sea are likely to pay 2.3
billion pounds more in tax a one-off
windfall tax will raise an additional
1.2 billion pounds let's put that money
into keeping bills lower for everybody
else
okay with respect to senator chancellor
um
it's okay for you to say that they're
having a terrific time uh because of
this the temporary spike in oil price uh
oil prices but from those in the
industry who actually have to pay the
bills they are saying that hasn't
particularly helped them and actually
things are going pretty much south so
how do you respond to their view that
actually
it may help somebody but it certainly
isn't helping them and that what you
might be doing is preparing for the
decimation
of our energy sector
well chancellors have used this device
before of increasing taxes on north sea
oil and gas when revenues and profits
are particularly high the previous
chancellor george osborne did it in 2011
gordon brown and before him margaret
thatcher also increased taxes for a
short period of time on north sea oil
and gas when prices were particularly
high and those windfall profits were
being made at any chancellor any shadow
chancellor has to make choices about
where to tax and where to spend i want
to tax fairly and spend wisely but when
those excess profits are being made it
does make sense to have a windfall tax
and use that money to keep bills down
for everybody else because unless action
is taken and taken soon
millions of families and pensioners
across the country
are staring into a huge cost of living
crisis as you said earlier trevor an
increase in national insurance at the
same time that gas and electricity bills
are going to explode potentially up by
700 pounds a year for bill payers
i we cannot stand by as the government
are currently doing and allowing those
price increases to go ahead when action
can be taken now to reduce bills
especially for those who are the squeeze
middle on lower incomes of pensioner
families uh as well action has to be
taken taken to avert this crisis that is
coming down the line okay just one more
chance on this i'm not going to argue
with you about the nature of the problem
i'm talking i'm asking about the nature
of the solution um
you are
projecting a windfall tax on a declining
industry reserves are declining which
already says it's squeezed and actually
they um
that though the big oil companies are
going elsewhere to develop are you are
you happy to uh project a plan which
essentially will uh
will
make britain more dependent on energy
supplies from others for example uh mr
putin's got lots of oil and gas uh are
you happy that we are
making him smile this morning by saying
we might have to depend more on him
plan my plan trevor is the exact
opposite we need to wean ourself off
imported gas from russia and qatar and
elsewhere and that's why in the plan
that i'm setting out today is also a big
boost in investment in renewables and in
nuclear in our hydrogen industry so we
are not reliant that is why the uk is
uniquely exposed because the government
got rid of the gas reserves has dithered
and delayed for over a decade on new
nuclear and in investment in renewables
and as a result we are particularly
exposed to that imported gas from
countries like russia who do have us
over a barrel and that is why as well as
a short-term action to keep prices down
we've got to retrofit homes speed up
that investment in new nuclear and
renewables and ensure that we are never
in this position again because i said as
i say the uk is uniquely exposed to
these rising gas prices because of a
failure for over a decade now by this
government to take action and that's why
kia stammer and myself working with ed
miliband our shadow secretary of state
for climate and net zero have put
forward this balanced package of
measures to keep prices low by asking
those who are making big profits this
year to pay more into the system for
this one year only
forgive me i i know it's it's it's a bit
tricky because of the technicalities to
dave uh that you can't him hear me
interrupting but forgive me interrupting
you but the other part of your plan is
to cut vat on uh energy
bills um that's a bit odd for a labor
shadow chancellor isn't it because that
would be uh benefit richer households
relative to poorer households why not
just simply uh go straight to the tax
system i mean that would be a
progressive step rather than a
regressive way of dealing with the
problem
i'm setting out today three things to
keep bills low first of all a cut in vat
on gas and electricity bills from five
percent to zero for one year uh saving
uh households given the price rise we're
expected to see a hundred pounds a year
the second thing is smoothing the some
of the costs of the increase that we're
likely to see in april to take a further
100 pounds of bills but recognizing that
it is those on lower incomes families
and pensioners as well as well as those
who uh the squeezed middle uh who are
struggling with those rising bills and
rising tax putting extra support through
the warms homes discount to ensure that
those people get the help that is needed
an extra 400 pounds off their bills from
april uh this year to help them through
this difficult time with the prices high
and you'll know trevor that the prime
minister was the biggest advocate for
cutting vat on gas and electricity bills
during the european referendum but now
when cutting those bills would make more
difference than ever the prime minister
says no well i say that bills can't be
paid on broken promises the government
should honor that commitment that the
prime minister made to take vat of gas
and electricity prices if this isn't the
time to do it then frankly i don't know
when is
it it's a bit odd um rachel ruiz to to
hear you saying uh you want to follow a
boris johnson policy and i don't think
you've quite dealt with my question
about whether this is not uh a
regressive uh tax on households and
wouldn't a labor approach be to
uh impose a more progressive tax so that
you're not putting a relatively higher
burden on the low paid you can do all
the other things that you've mentioned i
hear all that but this particular
cut would mean that better off
households benefit relative to the poor
why are you doing that
well in fact it is the poorer households
who spend a higher proportion of their
spending on gas and electricity bills
and that is particularly so for
pensioner households who are at home
more and need to keep their homes warm
so i don't buy this um idea that cutting
vit is somehow a regressive policy but
we are making sure that through this
package of measures we're announcing
today and the windfall tax on those
excess profits of north sea oil and gas
are used particularly to benefit those
people on lower incomes families and
pensioners with additional support for
the warm homes discount so support for
all with that cut in v80 but extra
support for those who need it most that
is the progressive thing to do but it
also recognizes that everybody right now
is facing through no fault of their own
big increases in prices in april
government can do something about it
they must choose to act because without
action a combination of national
insurance increases council tax
increases and this catastrophe of higher
domestic gas and electricity bills will
be a disaster for families and
pensioners in just a couple of months
time
rachel reese thank you very much for
your time this morning